.
Donnerstagmorgen, 27. Februar.
Das Coronavirus
ist im Bündnerland angekommen.
Der Kantonale Führungsstab
ist ab sofort aktiv.
Martin Bühler ist dessen Chef.
Wir wissen seit gestern Abend
von diesen zwei bestätigten Fällen.
Damit haben wir eine Art Eskalation.
Wir wussten zwar,
dass das kommen könnte
und haben uns auch
darauf vorbereitet.
Jetzt ist es aber nötig,
sich spezifisch auf diese
neue Situation auszurichten.
Bühlers Begleiter
ist Christian Florin,
Leiter Infrastruktur
der Rhätischen Bahn.
Guten Tag.
Das Zugpersonal
ist bereits über hygienische
Massnahmen instruiert worden.
Danke.
Wir verteilen ja jetzt dieses
Mittel. Haben Sie das schon?
Ja, das habe ich hier.
- Sie haben es dabei?
Da haben wir ja dasselbe.
- Ja, das passt.
Haben die Informationen
Sie erreicht?
Sehr gut, ja.
Wir werden gut informiert.
Nutzen Sie auch die Internetseite?
- Ja, jeden Tag.
Sind Sie aufgrund der Situation
etwas beunruhigt?
Nein, eigentlich noch gar nicht.
Wir werden gut informiert.
Auch was die Hygienevorschriften
usw. betrifft.
Es ist jetzt etwas anders:
Die Passagiere halten den SwissPass
jetzt ans Gerät,
wir nehmen ihn
nicht mehr in die Hand.
Kann es im schlimmsten Fall sein,
dass die RhB den Betrieb einstellt?
Falls der Worst Case eintritt,
kann es zu Problemen für uns kommen,
v.a. im grenzüberschreitenden
Verkehr Richtung Italien.
Das können wir aber
nicht allein entscheiden.
Das müssten wir
mit SBB und Bund abklären.
Wir dürfen den Zugverkehr nicht ein-
fach einschränken oder einstellen.
Das müssten wir ganz klar
mit dem Bund abstimmen.
Die beiden sind unterwegs
zu einer Krisensitzung.
Sie haben ja auch Familie.
Machen Sie sich da Sorgen?
Natürlich macht man sich
um die Familie Sorgen.
Aber im Zusammenhang
mit dem Coronavirus muss ich sagen:
Wir wohnen in einem kleinen Dorf,
sind über die
zu treffenden Massnahmen informiert
und ich denke,
wenn wir das so machen,
sollte der Familie nichts passieren.
Regierungsrat Peter Peyer,
Vorsteher des Departements Justiz,
Sicherheit und Gesundheit,
informiert, wie das Coronavirus
in den Kanton Graubünden kam.
Wir haben eben diese beiden
bestätigten Fälle im Oberengadin,
in St. Moritz.
Kinder einer Familie aus Italien ...
... sind im Moment im Spital.
Dann haben wir
diverse Verdachtsfälle im Kanton,
aber auch Verdachtsfälle,
die sich als negativ erwiesen haben.
Da ändern die Zahlen ständig.
Unser Plan: Wir werden um 15 Uhr
die Gemeinden informieren.
Wir haben in den Regionen
Engiadina Bassa/Val Müstair, Maloja,
Bernina, Moesano
folgende Massnahmen ergriffen:
keine Grossanlässe, d.h. insbeson-
dere kein Frauenlauf am Sonntag,
keine Fastnachts-Veranstaltungen.
Die Schule startet am Montag
wieder normal,
aber es gibt keine Schulreisen
ins Ausland -
da machen wir es gleich
wie das Tessin.
Diese Massnahmen gelten alle
bis Montagabend, 2. März.
Und am Montag im Laufe des Tages
machen wir eine Neubeurteilung
und besprechen, wie es weitergeht.
Etwas vom Grössten,
was noch offen ist:
Was passiert
mit dem Engadiner Skimarathon,
der in einer Woche stattfindet?
Da haben wir noch nicht entschieden.
Je kurzfristiger die Entscheidung
vor dem Anlass gefällt wird,
desto grösser ist der Schaden -
nicht nur finanziell.
Jeder Teilnehmer,
die freiwilligen Helfer -
einige nehmen Ferien
während dieser Woche, um zu helfen -
da sind viele Menschen
involviert ...
Darf ich dazu etwas sagen?
- Ja.
Ich glaube,
am Schluss versteht es niemand,
wenn wir jetzt nicht absagen.
Was ist denn die Konsequenz,
wenn wir schon jetzt die Anlässe
von nächster Woche absagen?
Aufgrund der jetzigen Lage
kann man das nicht rechtfertigen.
Aber wenn wir natürlich auf die Welt
blicken, auf China und Italien,
dann werden sich die Fälle
bis nächstes Wochenende
exponentiell vervielfacht haben.
Es bringt nichts, jetzt zu zögern.
Denn es ist mehr klar als unklar:
Es gibt eine Zunahme,
wir haben bestätigte Fälle
und die Veranstaltung selber
ist an sich risikobehaftet.
Ist das gut? Also gut ist es nicht,
aber machen wir das so?
Es ist der richtige Weg.
Die Runde beschliesst
schweren Herzens,
den Engadiner Skimarathon abzusagen.
Der vorläufige Höhepunkt
einer Entwicklung,
welche die Medien seit einem
guten Monat intensiv beschäftigt.
In China breitet sich eine bisher
nicht bekannte Lungenkrankheit aus.
In diesem Tiermarkt in Wuhan habe
alles begonnen, berichten die Medien.
Das neuartige Coronavirus sei vom
Tier auf den Menschen übergesprungen.
Anfang Dezember
werden die ersten Infizierten
in die Spitäler der Stadt
eingeliefert.
Am 23. Januar dann der Shutdown:
Die 11-Mio.-Stadt Wuhan
wird hermetisch abgeriegelt.
Heute wissen wir:
Das Virus findet trotzdem einen Weg -
von Wuhan in die ganze Welt.
Das Bundesamt für Gesundheit
rechnet von Anfang an damit,
dass es wohl auch in der Schweiz
zu Coronafällen kommen wird.
Die Frage ist nur wann.
Und wie viele.
Im Moment ist es unmöglich,
mit der jetzigen Information
gesichert zu sagen,
wo die Reise hingeht.
Das nationale Referenzlabor in Genf
macht sich bereit,
um Proben von Verdachtsfällen
zu testen.
Shanghai am vergangenen Freitag.
SRF-Korrespondentin Claudia Stahel
macht sich auf den Weg,
um einen Beitrag zu filmen.
Sie hat eine Spezialkarte erhalten,
die sie vorweisen muss,
wenn sie aus dem Haus will.
In Shanghai gibt es mittlerweile
Zeichen der Entspannung.
Immer mehr Läden öffnen wieder.
Laut WHO ist der Höhepunkt
der Epidemie in China überschritten.
Aber man müsse weiter wachsam sein.
Es ist noch ein weiter Weg
zurück zur Normalität,
aber langsam
kehrt das öffentliche Leben zurück.
Diese Bar
ist ab sofort wieder geöffnet -
ganz zur Freude
des italienischen Besitzers.
Man hat uns informiert,
dass wir wieder aufmachen dürfen.
Ich denke, das generelle Ziel ist,
dass wir langsam und geordnet
zum Alltag zurückkehren.
Während sich die Lage in weiten
Teilen Chinas allmählich entspannt,
spitzt sie sich in Europa laufend zu.
In immer mehr Ländern
gibt es bestätigte Coronafälle.
In China verfolgt man natürlich,
was in Europa
mit dem Coronavirus passiert,
aber es gibt keine grosse
Selbstkritik, dass man sich fragt,
warum man die Ausbreitung auf andere
Länder nicht verhindern konnte.
Solche Kritik findet man weder in
den Medien noch von der Regierung.
Denn das wäre
ein Zeichen der Schwäche
und das passt nicht
zum Selbstbild Chinas,
dass man eine Weltmacht
und auf Augenhöhe des Westens ist.
Viel eher denkt man hier,
der Westen könnte
im Umgang mit diesem Virus
auch etwas von China lernen.
In China passierte lange nichts, dann
wurde Entschlossenheit demonstriert.
Die Millionenstadt Wuhan
ist z.B. weiter abgeriegelt.
Ein einziger Schweizer
ist noch vor Ort -
zusammen mit seiner chinesischen Frau
und seinen Kindern.
Wir sind jetzt seit einem Monat
in Wuhan eingeschlossen.
Die schlimmen Fälle
werden in den Spitälern behandelt.
Die leichteren
sind in einer Isolationszone,
damit sie die anderen
nicht anstecken.
Bei uns klingelt es regelmässig
an der Tür:
Dann überprüfen die Behörden
unsere Temperatur.
Alle sind ständig unter Beobachtung.
Das ist klar.
Anfangs durfte er noch
jeden dritten Tag einkaufen gehen.
Damit ist es jetzt vorbei.
Seit einer Woche sind er und seine
Familie in der Wohnung blockiert.
Sie dürfen nur noch
den Abfall rausbringen.
Das Essen
müssen sie im Internet bestellen.
Jeden fünften Tag gibt es eine
Lieferung, die sie abholen dürfen.
Dann müssen sie zurück
in ihre Wohnung.
Inzwischen ist das Virus
auch in Europa angekommen.
Seit einer Woche werden in Italien
ganze Orte abgeriegelt.
Keiner kommt mehr ins Sperrgebiet -
und keiner mehr raus.
Normalität derweil
an der Schweizer Grenze zu Italien.
Besondere Massnahmen
sind hier nicht geplant.
Es war nur noch eine Frage der Zeit,
jetzt hat auch die Schweiz
ihren ersten Coronavirus-Fall.
Ein 70-jähriger Tessiner
wird positiv auf das Virus getestet.
Er wird in einer Privatklinik
in Lugano in Quarantäne genommen,
aus der er inzwischen
wieder entlassen wurde.
Medienkonferenz
mit dem Tessiner Kantonsarzt,
als der erste Schweizer Fall
bestätigt ist.
Der Zustand des Infizierten
sei stabil, sagt er den Journalisten.
Doch Giorgio Merlani ist nervös.
Seit Tagen spitzt sich die Lage zu.
Es ist eine Gratwanderung
zwischen Beschwichtigen
und Aufklären
über den Ernst der Lage.
Es ist eingetroffen,
was wir vorausgesagt haben.
Es war nur eine Frage der Zeit.
Das BAG informiert parallel darüber,
dass der infizierte Tessiner
vor seiner Einlieferung ins Spital
engen Kontakt
mit seiner Familie gehabt habe.
Es sei möglich,
dass andere angesteckt wurden.
Es gibt viele Fälle,
die niemanden anstecken.
Darum kann man noch nicht sagen, ob
dieser Fall andere angesteckt hat.
Aber selbstverständlich müssen jetzt
alle Kontaktpersonen aufgesucht
und 14 Tage
in Quarantäne genommen werden.
Laut dem Direktor
des Bundesamtes für Gesundheit
werden wegen des Tessiner Falles
aber weder Schulen geschlossen
noch Sportveranstaltungen abgesagt.
Eine Informationskampagne
reiche derzeit aus.
Sollte sich dies
auf die ganze Schweiz ausbreiten,
hätten wir eine besondere Lage,
mit Massnahmen, die dann
der Bundesrat beschliessen müsste.
Vorbereitet sein für eine Pandemie:
Der Pandemieplan des Bundes zeigt,
welche Massnahmen
bei einer starken Ausbreitung
theoretisch möglich wären.
Schulschliessungen,
Veranstaltungsverbote
und mit Vorschriften können
öffentliche oder private Unternehmen
geschlossen und ganze Gebiete
oder Regionen abgeriegelt werden.
Derart weitreichende Massnahmen
würde der Bundesrat festlegen.
Voraussetzung dafür
wäre eine sog. besondere Lage,
die das ganze Land betrifft.
Alles ist möglich.
Die Hauptpriorität des Bundesrates
ist einfach,
die Gesundheit der Bevölkerung
zu schützen.
Donnerstagnachmittag, 27. Februar.
Martin Bühler
eilt zum nächsten Termin.
Der Chef
des Kantonalen Führungsstabes
und weitere Entscheidungsträger
treten vor die versammelte Presse.
Geschätzte Anwesende,
herzlich willkommen.
Ihr zahlreiches Erscheinen zeigt,
dass die Sache
von grossem Interesse ist.
Was am Morgen
im kleinen Kreis besprochen wurde,
wird nun öffentlich gemacht.
Eine möglichst transparente Kommuni-
kation soll Vertrauen schaffen.
Was machen wir zurzeit?
Einerseits
geht es seit gestern darum,
die ansteigenden Kommunikations-
bedürfnisse zu befriedigen,
umfassend zu informieren,
das Gesundheitsamt
dabei zu unterstützen, dies zu tun.
Sie haben ja gesehen:
Auf der Webseite des Kantons
wurde eine Seite speziell
für das Coronavirus aufgeschaltet.
Durch die Pressekonferenz wird
Martin Bühler zur öffentlichen Figur.
Der Leiter des Amtes für Militär und
Zivilschutz ist ein gefragter Mann.
Martin Bühler, war es nötig,
den Engadiner Skimarathon abzusagen?
Wir haben die Entscheidung
mit dem Vertreter des OK abgewägt
und kamen zum Schluss,
dass es nötig ist.
Die Hauptaufgabe
in der ersten Phase war,
die Kommunikation zu unterstützen
und zu verstärken.
Es ist wichtig, dass wir
die Menschen gut informieren,
ihnen sagen, dass sie einen Beitrag
dazu leisten können,
dass es sich nicht ausbreitet.
Nicht nur die Medien
haben derzeit Fragen an Bühler,
sondern auch die Chefs von
anderen kantonalen Führungsstäben.
(Mann über Telefon) Wenn man einen,
drei oder fünf Fälle hat -
damit kann man je nach Grösse
des Kantons ja umgehen.
Wenn man aber - ich nenne jetzt
irgendeine Zahl - 200 Fälle hat,
dann kann man wohl
nicht mehr gleich damit umgehen.
War das bei euch ein Thema
oder nicht?
So wie du es formulierst,
war es kein Thema.
Weil wir sagten ...
Wir haben Infrastrukturen
identifiziert,
wo wir auch im grösseren Stil
Quarantänen einrichten könnten.
Ja, okay.
Ich muss nicht erst nachdenken,
wenn ich handlungsunfähig bin.
Was tut man also, damit man mög-
lichst lange handlungsfähig bleibt?
Wenn du davon ausgehst,
dass man Hunderte, Tausende ...
Dann müssen wir das wohl
mit dem Bund koordinieren.
Dann sagt das BAG, was wir machen.
Der Bündner Pandemieplan
wurde 2015 letztmals überarbeitet
und 2017 durchexerziert.
Darin geht es auch
um Lager wie dieses,
wo alles bereit ist für den Fall,
dass sich die Situation
weiter verschärft.
Hier sieht man jetzt
die eingelagerten Schutzmasken.
Das sind alles
medizinische Einwegmasken.
Wir bekamen vom Bundesamt für
Bevölkerungsschutz die Möglichkeit,
für Notfälle und hohe Prioritäten
Masken mit hoher Qualität
zu bestellen.
Davon machten wir sofort Gebrauch.
Die Masken sind angekommen.
Das sind die, oder?
- Genau.
Wie sehen die aus?
Lass sie verpackt.
Und das hier sind ...
Die sind nicht offen, oder?
Doch, wir haben sie vorbereitet.
Das sind die Einweg-Schutzmasken.
Davon haben wir 500'000 Stück.
Sie sind für die Nutzung
von 2-3 Std. gedacht.
Von diesem Raum aus könnte der Kanton
die Fragen der Bevölkerung
beantworten.
Generell läuft das
über die Hotline Grischun.
Wir haben zehn Telefonanschlüsse,
die wir jederzeit aktiv halten.
Zu jedem Telefon bräuchte er dann
noch einen Telefonisten.
Wie schnell wären sie bereit,
wenn es wirklich eilt?
Wir haben ein gewisses Detachement,
das per sofort,
auf Abruf bereit wäre.
D.h. in 1 Std.?
In 1-2 Std. wären ca. 13 Personen
einsatzbereit.
Und dann haben wir
noch mal rund 21 Personen,
die bei Bedarf
in 3-6 Std. einrücken könnten.
Das Coronavirus
verunsichert die Schweiz.
Ob es tatsächlich zu einer Pandemie
kommt, ist allerdings offen.
Die derzeitige Situation erinnert
an bekannte frühere Virusfälle
wie SARS oder Vogelgrippe.
Es beginnt jeweils mit Krankheits-
und Todesfällen in fremden Ländern.
Oft leiden und sterben
zunächst asiatische Menschen
an bis dahin noch unbekannten,
hoch ansteckenden Viruserkrankungen.
Gegen diese
gibt es keine Schutzimpfungen.
Diese Viren
verbreiten sich dann weltweit
und sorgen für Besorgnis,
auch in der Schweiz.
Die geheimnisvolle und gefährliche
asiatische Lungenentzündung,
die vor einigen Tagen
Europa erreicht hat,
sei eine weltweite Bedrohung.
Die Angst vor der Hühnergrippe
geht auch in der Schweiz um.
Die Furcht vor der Ausbreitung der
gefährlichen Lungenerkrankung SARS
durch Flugreisende wächst.
Bisher starben über zehn Menschen an
der rätselhaften Lungenentzündung.
Die Schweiz rüstet sich dann jeweils
für den Worst Case.
Krankheits- und Übertragungsrate
von Anfang an eindämmen,
heisst die Devise.
(Mann) Alles,
was mit dem Virus infiziert ist,
was man hier desinfiziert,
bleibt in dieser Wanne.
Im Rückblick wirkt manche Reaktion
übertrieben.
(Originalkommentar)
Schmuck- und Uhrenmesse Basel:
Jeder sechste Besucher
kommt aus Asien.
Bei solchen Massen auf engem Raum
ist die Ansteckungsgefahr gross.
Man denkt an SARS, das
lebensgefährliche Virus aus Asien.
C'est de l'hysterie.
(Originalkommentar)
Diese Hysterie sehen Apotheker.
Alle decken sich mit Tamiflu ein.
Völlig unnötigerweise,
sagen die Experten des Bundes.
Fakt ist: Hierzulande
sterben weit mehr Menschen
an herkömmlichen Grippeerkrankungen.
Sobald die virustragenden Tiere
einmal ausgemacht sind,
kommt es zu Massentötungen.
Die Ursprungsländer
wollen damit der Welt auch zeigen,
dass sie das Problem im Griff haben.
Forscher beginnen
nach Impfstoffen zu suchen.
Wie hier in Taiwan
werden vermeintliche Siege
über Viruserkrankungen wie SARS
öffentlich zelebriert.
Bis diese oder andere
dann doch wieder auftauchen.
Wird diesmal alles anders?
Christian Althaus,
Epidemienforscher an der Uni Bern,
schreibt auf Twitter:
Die wissenschaftliche
Fehleinschätzung des BAG
zur Gefährlichkeit des Coronavirus
sei "unverantwortlich".
In der "NZZ"
führt er zwei Tage später aus:
Und weil es keine Immunität
in der Bevölkerung gebe,
könnten sich
bis zu 40 % der Leute anstecken.
Es könnte also 3 Mio. Infizierte
und 30'000 Tote geben,
rechnet die "NZZ" vor -
und Althaus antwortet:
Wir sagen, das Risiko, dass man sich
in der Schweiz ansteckt,
ist bisher moderat.
Dieses Risiko kann sich natürlich
jederzeit ändern.
Wir veröffentlichen
keine hypothetischen Fall-
oder Sterblichkeitszahlen,
denn diese basieren auf Modellen.
Und wir versuchen,
mit der Wirklichkeit,
mit den echten Daten zu arbeiten.
Freitagmorgen, 28. Februar.
Rapport des kantonalen Führungsstabes
Graubünden.
... heute wieder Infogleichstand
herstellen,
Handlungsbedarf erkennen,
wo nötig Massnahmen einleiten.
Dann die Sicherstellung der
Kommunikation weiterführen, Anita.
Wir müssen wohl auch verstärken.
Bevor wir zur Lage kommen,
übergebe ich das Wort an Peter.
Guten Morgen. Ich will
eigentlich nicht viel sagen.
Ich will auch nicht
an jedem Lagerapport teilnehmen.
Aber nach gestern fand ich es
wichtig, einmal dabei zu sein.
Ich bekam gerade eine Anfrage
vom Schiesssportverband in Davos,
ob sie die DV morgen
durchführen sollen oder nicht.
Jetzt zieht das wohl an.
Wahrscheinliche Lageentwicklung:
Die Anzahl
abzuklärender Verdachtsfälle
wird in den nächsten Tagen
ansteigen.
In einigen Tagen kommt es zu einem
starken Anstieg an Erkrankungen
aufgrund lokaler Übertragungen.
Knappe Güter wie Hygienemasken
oder Desinfektionsmittel
werden demnächst ausverkauft sein
oder sind es z.T. schon.
Grossanlässe und Massenveran-
staltungen in den kommenden Wochen
müssen abgesagt werden.
Was wir z.T. ja schon verfügt haben.
Die Verunsicherung
in der Bevölkerung steigt an.
Es ist mit direkten Auswirkungen auf
das öffentliche Leben zu rechnen.
Und das mediale Interesse
nimmt weiter zu
und bildet entsprechende Ressourcen.
Die Schutzmaskenübersicht,
den ganzen Umgang mit den Anlässen -
v.a. den Umgang mit den Anlässen
sehe ich
als grösste Herausforderung.
In die Sitzung des Kantonalen
Führungsstabes platzt die Nachricht,
dass der Bundesrat eine sog.
besondere Lage ausgerufen hat.
Der Bund schreibt
in der Verordnung über Massnahmen
zur Bekämpfung des Coronavirus:
"Es ist verboten, öffentliche
oder private Veranstaltungen,
bei denen sich gleichzeitig
mehr als 1'000 Personen aufhalten,
in der Schweiz durchzuführen."
"Mehr".
- Mehr als 1'000 ist verboten.
Eine folgenschwere Entscheidung
aus Bern.
Bundesrat Alain Berset
erklärt sich den Medien.
Es ist wirklich nicht einfach,
diesen Schritt zu tun.
Aber in der Abwägung im Bundesrat
sind wir zum Schluss gekommen ...
Es ist für die nächsten zwei Wochen,
das ist nicht viel.
Vielleicht wird es geändert.
Aber für die nächsten zwei Wochen
müssen wir stark aufpassen.
Denn die oberste Priorität ist der
Schutz der öffentlichen Gesundheit.
Wenn es trotzdem zu Ansteckungen
kommt, sind die Spitäler gefordert.
Wir gehen zu den Zimmern,
die sicher sofort bereit sind ...
Martin Bühlers nächster Programmpunkt
an diesem Tag:
Er lässt sich vom Chefarzt
des Spitals Schiers
auf den neusten Stand
der Vorbereitungen bringen.
Gehen wir mal hinein.
Hier haben wir ein modernes
Unterdruck-Zimmer mit Filter.
D.h., die Luft aus dem Zimmer
kann nicht raus.
Die Luft von aussen kommt aber rein,
weil hier drin Unterdruck herrscht.
Hier würden wir
die ersten Patienten hineinbringen.
Dann zieht sich unser Mitarbeiter an
oder ist vorbereitet,
wenn es telefonisch
angekündigt wurde.
Er ist also schon gut geschützt.
Dann geht die Person hier rein.
Sie hören das Sauggeräusch.
Wir sind also super ausgestattet.
Aber was die mögliche
Aufnahmemenge betrifft,
sind wir im Gegensatz zu Grossspi-
tälern in einem bescheidenen Rahmen.
Aber Sie haben mit den Hausärzten
abgesprochen, wie Sie ...
Die haben alle schon angerufen.
- Sehr gut.
Und wir mussten tatsächlich
Masken organisieren.
Sie sind ja überall ausgegangen.
Aber der Kanton und der Bund
haben Masken auf der Seite.
Das wird organisiert. Und heute
soll die erste Lieferung ankommen.
Damit wir unser Materiallager
auffüllen können.
Danke. Das finde ich wichtig.
Die Kapazitätsgrenze
wäre schnell erreicht.
Knapp 20 Erkrankte
könnte das Spital Schiers aufnehmen.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Regina Kolb - 2020